I was in a restaurant in Malibu with Bob  chartoff and Lou Carlino who some of you  know bunch of fancy Hollywood type  people and there was this French  producer there this woman and she and I  had been seated together at dinner and  she said you see zedzee mushroom speaks  to you but I don't understand how this  can be what do you mean it speaks to you  and I see in and ralph abraham was there  too and i in my sincere way said well  it's like the parts tiger played in the  pawnbroker it just and at that moment  Steiger stops by the table to shake  hands with everybody there and I'm like  true story true story and Ralph who's  watched this whole thing go down leans  across the table to me and says what  this proves is the mushroom can reach  into our world no matter where we are  and shake the bars